all right let's start today with a
weekly coronavirus update
it does seem increasingly like what we
said last week might be going on
is going on which is that the plateau
in the decline in cases and deaths that
we saw last week was not really a
plateau it wasn't really a reversal
it was an artifact of the storms in much
of the country
which slowed down testing and
vaccination
i'll explain in more detail but let's
just
jump right into the numbers starting
with cases of course
on january 11th we saw the average
peak of daily cases hit 250
55 000 cases per day a number
that a year ago would have been
inconceivable when dr fauci said
we might get to 100 000 cases a day so
many people saying
no we won't and we got to an average of
255
000 cases a day as of january 11th but
then we
saw a reverse and the numbers started to
decline and we saw
average case numbers go below 200 000 a
day below 150 000 a day below a hundred
thousand a day
down to about seventy thousand cases a
day and then around february 19th
20th the decline appeared to stop case
numbers even went up a few days now my
idea was
this is not a real increase this is
because of the bad weather in the united
states
why would that be the storms that push
texas into blackout conditions right
around
mid-february led to lower than actual
numbers being reported for some time so
the decline we saw in mid-february
was bigger than reality because a lot of
testing was being delayed
at the end of february as testing got
caught up we were getting
more cases reported than the real number
of new cases
as the backlog tests were processed so
yesterday was the day
with the fewest cases since october 13th
right around 52 000 cases and i believe
that that's the real number i think
there was a period between january 11th
and yesterday
where numbers were artificially low and
then a period where numbers were
artificially high i think that the
backlog has been cleared
and we're now back to sort of the real
numbers one example
a friend of mine's dad was tested
around february 15th it took 11 days to
get the results
that it tested positive he's doing fine
he's actually vaccinated and has no
symptoms whatsoever
that is a positive test that should have
shown up far earlier but because of the
delays that didn't show up until
february 28th so bottom line
cases from the peak on january 11th down
73
that's a great number we're closing in
on getting below 50 000 a day that would
be
an important milestone now in terms of
deaths a very similar trajectory
deaths peaked at about 3 400 today on
january 26th
from that point deaths are down 42
percent
we saw a similar bump right as the
storms passed and the data normalized
there is no doubt
that 1900 deaths a day which is where we
are now
is outrageous but if you have outrageous
tragic numbers
that are going down you prefer that to
outrageous tragic numbers that are going
up
another important statistic that we
track are hospitalizations
good news there is that hospitalizations
are down from a peak of more than 130
000 just after uh the start of 2021
down from 130k to about 52
000 hospitalizations that's a
hospitalization decline
of about 60 percent as more and more
high-risk people get vaccinated
that number should decline more now the
really exciting news if there's anything
exciting at all to look at
in the midst of horrible tragedy that's
coming from vaccines we now have a third
vaccine
given an emergency use authorization
this is the johnson
johnson vaccine it is a one dose vaccine
now there are people who were negative
on this vaccine saying
oh it's less efficacious than the pfizer
and modern vaccines
and there are three important things to
consider there number one
the johnson and johnson vaccine even if
less effective at preventing infections
appears to be just as good as the other
vaccines at preventing
serious covid and keeping people out of
hospitals all right so
number one that's very important number
two
it's only one dose meaning that given x
number of doses
if you have five million jnj doses you
can vaccinate five million people rather
than just 2.5 million if you had that
same number of pfizer
or modernity doses because it's one dose
only
and number three it's not actually clear
that the jnj vaccine really is
not as good at preventing infection now
i know the headlines are often pfizer
moderna 95
effective jnj only 65-70
there are studies these are still
pre-prints so take everything with with
some skepticism
now but there are studies that suggest
that because the jnj phase 3 trials
were tested on the variants that we're
so worried about
including the south africa variant that
the lower number the 65
70 percent reflects the variance
and that if you were to do the pfizer
and moderna trials
with the variants you would also be
seeing 65
70 so the point is it's not really clear
jnj is less effective
get whatever vaccine is available and
we had a very good three-day period this
past weekend
friday saturday sunday where almost
7 million doses were injected over the 3
days 6.9 million doses in fact
so we are now averaging 1.8 million
doses a day
joe biden wanted to do a million a day
for a hundred days
we might be able to double that we might
be able to more than double it we we
could even be getting to 2.5
or 3 million doses a day regularly soon
as there are massive dumps of vaccine
doses
coming in march realistically it
it's conceivable that the problem by the
end of this month
will be do we have enough vaccination
sites
and vaccinators to inject all of the
doses that we're going to have
some locations probably need to start
thinking about ramping up
to 24 7 vaccination that's a good
problem to have
assuming you can solve it we want to
make sure that we can uh use all of the
doses that we're getting so
things are looking up it's a race
against the variance
it's again a race against people
behaving less carefully because of the
good news
but uh i i continue to be cautiously
optimistic
we'll check in again in another week
send me your thoughts about what's going
on locally with vaccines where you live
you can find me on twitter at d pacman
after the break
we are going to talk about cancel
culture yes it's the rights new
obsession
many requests for a sort of overview
about cancel culture as the new pet
issue for the right there's very
specific reasons why the right is
focused on it
um you can also make sure you're
following us on instagram at david
pakman show for more
on all of these stories we'll take a
quick break and be back with
much more today's episode is sponsored
by bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month's supply for
free take a short quiz on the bluechew
website
a licensed doctor approves your
prescription and the medication goes
right to your home in a discreet package
no driving to the doctor's office
having a possibly awkward conversation
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluechu replaces the entire process with
a few
clicks and way less expensive and all of
bluechews tablets are made
in the united states so if you think you
could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
go to bluechew.com the link is under
this video and they'll give you an
entire month's supply for
free when you use promo code pacman just
pay five dollars for shipping